[Music]
so
[Music]
this is sky news today it's 11 o'clock
the headlines
household bills predicted to rise by up
to 600 pounds a year as the energy price
cap is due to more than double
but some relief to household to be
pledged by the chancellor he'll make an
announcement in the commons later this
hour
awash with cash as households struggle
shells profits are buoyed by rising
wholesale gas prices
markets predict an interest rate rise
from the bank of england to tackle
rising inflation we'll find out if
they're right at noon
i'm at a food bank talking to families
hard hit by the cost of living and
forced to choose between heating and
eating
it stayed warm for about 10 15 minutes
and then that's it
even if we're under quilt we have hot
water bottle it's still cold and we just
sit there shaking and everything
also coming up this afternoon
sky news understands northern ireland's
first minister is expected to resign
amid the row over post-brexit border
checks
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet
and hello mr bond daniel craig's final
outing as double07 is among the
favorites as the bafta nominees are
announced later today
[Music]
good morning live from stoke on trent
millions of people here and across the
country about to find out just how much
their energy bills will rise from this
april
well that's because the energy regulator
of gem is to announce the new price cap
that's the maximum amount providers can
charge dual fuel customers
well the energy regulator is expected to
announce a price cap rise of about 50
percent
that means bills of around 1
900 to 2000 pounds per year compared to
the current figure that stands at around
1
200 a year
i think we can uh cross now to uh paul
kelso who can uh break the news for us
now on that uh price hike call over to
you yes the uh regulator off gem has
announced that the new price cap for a
standard use average use of a dual fuel
bill will rise to 1970
pounds that's up uh just uh almost
exactly 700 pounds from the current rate
of uh
127 pounds so a major increase nudging
50 percent as many analysts had
predicted it reflects the huge increase
in wholesale gas prices that have driven
up the costs for suppliers over the last
six months have caused more than 25
suppliers of energy to go bust placing
pressure right across the board
stripping out the cheaper options the
switching options for customers to seek
cheaper bills and they are now looking
at from april the first the average
dual fuel bill will be capped at
1971 pounds that is forecast to push at
least another 2 million households into
fuel stress or fuel poverty and it will
of course beg a response from the
government this is the kind of price
increase to a necessary utility that no
one can do without
that is going to affect not just the
poorest in society but median income
households uh almost everyone is going
to feel the scale of this uh in their
pockets worth remembering that a year
ago the price cap was just over a
thousand pounds so it was very nearly
doubled in the space of
a year and if today's news wasn't enough
for people to try and digest the
forecast is in the six months time given
the
ex the state of the gas market and the
expectation prices will remain high it
could be going up again too well north
of 2000 pounds so we will hear in the
next half hour or so the response from
the floor of the house of commons from
the chancellor of the exchequer we've
talked about uh we've had uh briefings
and suggestions of various measures to
uh take money off these bills perhaps
200 pounds rebated to every customer but
given the stay scale of this increase
the price cap now just shy of 2 000
pounds even a 200 pound rebate is going
to leave
every household at least certainly 22
million households who are on standard
variable rates are still going to be
looking at a 500 pound increase of 50
pounds a month uh getting on for 50
pounds a month anyway increasing their
fuel bills and with interest rates due
to go up later today inflation as it
stands north of five percent and tax
rises coming in april uh there will be a
great deal of attention on what the
chancellor uh announces he's going to do
about this cost of living squeeze uh in
about half an hour
okay paul for the moment thank you a lot
of pain coming to a lot of people and as
paul said there the chancellor ishisunak
will be taking to his feet in the
commons
that's to deliver his statement in
response to that energy
price cap at around 11 30 this morning
that's in just under half an hour's time
do stay with us for all of that
and that price rise will affect many
people here in stoke on trent the price
rise will affect many people here in
stoke-on-trent one of the 10 local
authorities worse affected by fuel
poverty
that means many households here are
spending more than 10 percent of their
income on energy bills that's after
paying their rent or their mortgage
well even before the pandemic there were
3.2 million households in england living
in fuel poverty
more than 25 000 households in
stoke-on-trent that's 21.8 percent our
fuel poor meaning the city has the
second highest rate of fuel poverty in
the country
stoke-on-trent food bank provided food
aid to 14 000 people in 2020.
this year 1500 people received food aid
who had never used a food bank before
and one charity says it's provided more
aid in the first two months of 2021 than
in the whole of 2018.
and our business correspondent helen ann
smith joins me now from one of
stoke-on-trentser food banks astonishing
stats there helena that many people had
simply never used them before
yeah absolutely and that's something
we've heard this morning that lots of
people coming to this food bank in
slokon trent have never used them before
they're not the sort of people who you
would typically historically associate
with needing to come to food banks they
are people who are working uh they're
people who are holding down multiple
jobs and simply the cost of living
squeeze is just so high at the moment
that they need to come to places like
this in desperation this is really a
community center jillian people coming
for a cup of tea sometimes uh to get
some extra help with their food but also
crucially uh to get some advice uh
there's advice services money matters uh
to help people try and manage their
bills just to put this in some context
julian uh
it's estimated that that rise in energy
bills we've just confirmed just shy of
700 pounds a year on top of what people
already paying
that could push as many as a quarter of
uk households into fuel poverty a
quarter just think of that so it's a
huge huge problem for people as at the
same time the inflation is rising
massively the cost of food the cost of
fuel at the pumps tax increases coming
down the line it is desperate desperate
times for a lot of people i'm just going
to walk you over this way because i want
to introduce you to a gentleman who
knows what this is like who's been
dealing with people uh on the front line
and giving them advice crucially uh in
terms of how they can better uh look
after themselves sorry to interrupt this
is collin ayers uh working uh for money
matters here helping people giving them
some advice colin it's a really
difficult time for families we've just
had it confirmed just how much fuel
bills are going to go up 700 pounds just
shy of
what's your response to that in terms of
the people you're seeing here and the
people you're helping i mean that's
worse than i was expecting we're
expecting about five six hundred pounds
you know that's it makes me extremely
angry that um
how can that be justifiable clearly the
energy market's broken clients that come
in here are struggling for food they're
struggling to heat and it used to be
either heat or eat and now it's they're
not going to be able to do whatever so
someone on universal credit
that potentially means a bill for them
going up by about 50 of what they get
coming in
someone who's on minimum wage that's at
least 10 percent of their income that's
that's a lot more i was expecting
and you've said you've really seen a
change in the type of people coming here
to seek your advice in terms of how
they're managing their bills yes so
since i've been doing this role over 18
months i think we've seen about 50
increase in clients that need our help
which is giving money advice benefit
advice debt advice and energy advice
and it's there's a difference happening
so there are people who are in poverty
or on benefits or are not claiming
benefit but they're working everyday
people who are now struggling we're
going to see more it's we've been
running a service since 2009 and things
have been getting worse and worse and
worse and quite clearly something's very
broken right now and the energy industry
is very broken i worked there for 19
years and i've never seen anything like
this and put it into some context if
people's bills are just shy of 2 000
pounds a year going up by just shy of
700 pounds on average what does that
mean in practical terms for the people
who you're talking to every day well you
think about that that's that's easily 60
70 quid a month for some people well if
you literally might not be able to eat
as a result of that or you might put
yourself into debt you might not know
how to cope i'm worried about it and i'm
working i'm sure you are as well but for
somebody that is like which could be 50
of their income in some way so where are
they going to go there are support
services there but there are not enough
support services there we struggle to
take everyone on board that we would
need to do places like the cab struggle
as well so i'm concerned about who's
going to fall through the cracks we can
help so many people but it's a finite
service where they're going to go and
people who don't have a voice who don't
even come here what's going to happen to
them do they end up very homeless
because they get behind on the bills
because they start not paying their rent
instead of paying their energy because
nobody wants to be cold and everyone
needs to be able to heat the food
that's what concerns me and there is
speculation it looks likely that the
government might sort of introduce a
loan scheme of sorts to the energy
companies which would mean a rebate of
about 200 pounds per household
is that going to make enough of a
difference 700 quid going up 200 pounds
that's five that's still 500 quid that
someone's got to find 30 40 quid a month
you know where
it's not fixing the problem the energy
industry is broken has been broken for
some time but particularly this last
couple years we've never seen rises like
this
throwing 200 credit ate the problem
there's something broken at the core
and that's what they need to fix and
they've known this has been coming for a
bit the price cap went up last year now
it's going up by about 50 60
compared to where it was
i don't know how people are going to
cope
we've been talking a bit this morning
colin and you sound quite angry about
the situation i'm generally shocked that
it's even worse than we thought so
what's that going to be now it's going
to be like 2 grand a year isn't it
rather than 1900 i think we all thought
it might be slightly less and we're all
probably being a little bit over the top
it's too much how can people cope with
that
it's you know most people are going to
struggle with where's the 670 per month
going to come from and what's going to
have to go as a result of it do they
turn their energy down to a
level where it's going to make them ill
do you drop it below you know 18 to 21
below 18 you start getting cold related
illnesses some people are going to have
to feel like they have to do that
you know and that's just ordinary
working people it's not enough to just
have an energy efficiency advice the
energy market's broken it needs fixing
and you're very very worried about the
coming months and years then in terms of
people you're helping yeah well this'll
this will come in first of april we've
seen our eyes in clients as it is more
than we can cope with
come first of april and this kicks in
it'll take a couple of months before it
starts to bleed through but think about
this that 700 is going to affect your
shopping bill because all these
companies have got to absorb this so
everything is going to go up as the
result is not just the energy bill alone
it's everything if you have your shop
it'll be where you go so there's going
to be a massive massive shift in
people's ability to be able to spend
anything right now on top of kovid colin
thank you so much for your time
to put it in some context again julian
there were roughly around 2 million
households
prior to this rise that are spending in
excess of 10 of their disposable income
on their energy bills that's expected to
triple to around 6 million households so
although the people who might be needing
to come to a place like this uh are
experiencing really very desperate
situations this is going to affect
millions and millions and millions of
people who are struggling greatly at the
moment with the cost of living
thank you so much for that absolutely
certainty there that it will affect
millions of people so while people face
the prospect of steep rises in their
energy bills the oil and gas company
shell has announced a profit of 17
billion dollars for 2021
despite
soaring wholesale gas and oil prices the
company had fourth quarter profits of
6.4 billion dollars
it's their best quarter since 2014 and
has led to renewed calls for a windfall
tax on north sea energy firms in order
to support consumers
let's cross live now to our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
and hannah many clamoring to say that
these profits simply need to be passed
on
yes the energy business is a volatile
one of course shell amongst the many uh
big operators that reported huge losses
in 2020 because of the reducing demand
during covet at now reporting huge
record-breaking profits because of the
spiking price of energy that spiking
price of course brings so much pain to
millions of families uh in the uk and
this is all prompting renewed calls from
the labour party and others for a
windfall tax on fossil fuel companies
operating in the north sea to help
alleviate the pain
of four consumers now shell had an
earnings call its ceo
ben van burden was questioned very
closely on the issue of a windfall tax
and this is what he said
it is a concerning picture and we
completely understand that
but what i said also in response to a
previous question of course this is
driven very much by a by a global
dynamic which has a small player like we
are with sort of one and a half percent
of energy supplies
there's only so much that that of course
can be done by company like us i am not
convinced that windfall texas popular
dota machine
is going to help us with supply nor is
it going to help us with demand
shell's results and of course results of
other energy companies which are
expected to be similarly uh good from a
business point of view have given new
momentum to a couple of interesting
debates that we've been tracking at sky
news the first is the broader tax
environment in the united kingdom which
is widely considered to be a very good
place to do business if you are a fossil
fuel
operator
we have reported on sky news before that
shell is amongst many companies
operating in the north sea that actually
paid negative tax last year and there
are broader questions about whether or
not that should be sustainable given the
uk is trying to be a climate leader the
government might argue that it's the
right thing to make
this a stable an advantageous tax
environment for fossil fuel companies so
that they can be kept in place in order
to invest in the transition to renewable
energy and the second is more of a
political row really a growing round
within the conservative party that there
are those now saying in order to
increase energy security in the united
kingdom and potentially even bring down
prices for consumers there should be
more drilling for gas
in the north sea and there are others
within the same party saying that is not
the answer we have to make the
transition to renewables faster so
plenty of scrutiny for many reasons on
those shells results today
hannah thank you
you can follow all the energy price cap
developments on our website by scanning
the qr code on screen now you can follow
today's stories and read the live
updates on the sky news live blog
well let's bring you some breaking news
now about the wraith rovers footballer
david goodwill our scotland
correspondent james matthews uh can
bring us up to date on that uh james
what can you tell us
yeah thanks very much indeed i can tell
you there has been a reversal of this
most controversial signing david
goodwilly was signed by wraith rovers
who play here at starks park in kirkaudi
earlier in the week it prompted an
outcry because he is a rapist he is
adjudged or was a judge by a civil court
in 2007 to have raped a woman laterally
he's been playing for clyde football
club previously played for blackburn
rovers and dundee united but he was
playing for clyde signed by wraith
rovers and that prompted an outcry with
prominent supporters including the
former prime minister gordon brown very
critical so too val mcdermott the famous
crime writer big fan steeped in wraith
rovers history her father was the scout
who spotted the great jim baxter she has
been a short sponsor that stand is named
the val mcdermott stan she became a
board member she cut ties and
effectively led a very fast growing
campaign against the signing the captain
of the women's team
left
wraith rovers women's side so there was
a huge amount of protests joined by
nicola sturgeon as well she was critical
of scotland's first minister sponsors
uh were withdrawing their funding board
directors
stepped down so there was huge pressure
on this club in kirkaudi and this
morning in a statement on the club
website they have announced uh that he
won't be selected for the club and they
are in discussions with him about his
contract so he's clearly on his way out
i'll read you some of the uh that club
statement it is a foolsome apology
they say
uh they want to apologize this is a
chairman i personally want to apologize
wholeheartedly to our fans sponsors
players and the wider wraith rovers
community for the anguish and anger
caused over the past few days
we got it wrong he's he says in reaching
our original decision we focused far too
much
on football matters and not enough on
what the decision would mean for our
club and the community as a whole over
the past few days
uh we listened carefully to the fans who
got in touch i'm very grateful for their
honesty as chairman as a board and as a
management team this statement says we
have all learned a hard but valuable
lesson
statement calls it a very unfortunate
episode brutally regretted by the club
who say they are now wholly committed to
making things right and the statement
says i can therefore confirm that
following a meeting of the wraith
rover's board
the player will not be selected by
wraith rovers and we will enter into
discussions
with the player regarding his
contractual position we share a desire
to do what's best for our club and we'll
be doing everything on our part to
regain the trust and confidence of the
wraith rovers family juliana i can tell
you just looking at my twitter timeline
it's clear that that road to recovery
may be a long one many people saying
well luke that's fine but this the
signing of a rapist should never have
happened
in the first place it may be
a long road to recovery but they have
taken a step on that road within the
past half hour
james thank you
we're back to the cost of living news
today and the bank of england is
expected to announce a rise in the
interest rate
an attempt to stem the flow of rising
inflation it's already increased to 0.25
percent this year it's now widely
forecast to go up again to 0.5
with many expecting yet more increases
later in
2022.
and we'll bring you that decision as it
happens right here on sky news at 12 p.m
midday with all the reaction from our
economics editor ed conway
ahead of hearing the bank of england
governor himself a little later that'll
be at around half past
12.
joining me now is jason powner he's
joining me now he owns uh the skin jace
tattoo studio here in stoke on trent uh
welcome to you found out fun fact this
morning neil morrison got tattooed inked
right here in stockholm trent did you
know that
yeah
now we really want to find out um
how your business is going to be
affected by
these increases i mean how's it been
let's talk about that the the period of
pandemic so far how has business been
like um business has been okay for me
personally um
as regards to the food bank it's always
been a problem within the the snow
contract area and prior to the pandemic
we were always kind of busy with that um
i can only presume with what's going on
with the um
with the short you know with the the
power cut you know with the power
i can only i can only see it being a
bigger problem than it actually is now
uh
with the the dishing out to the food
banks now there is plenty of people
around snow content small local
businesses like myself
that do go out there and we aren't the
local people of stoke on trent
um
but we need a lot more local businesses
to join in with us
we have local football clubs port vale
foundation they do a lot for the local
community um
there's lots and lots of people within
the area
um but with obviously with what's going
on with the energy energy price is the
increase i can only see the problem
being a lot more you know
yeah more than 50 percent uh increase 1
971 a year that's an awful lot of money
for people to find that are struggling
right now yeah
um again
myself and my business
um i can only
like everybody else i mean we're gonna
have to you know put up with the with
the the increase in prices
um
but i don't know i don't know with the
people that are struggling now the
elderly the vulnerable
i can only i can just see just getting a
lot worse things actually as you know
right now
what will it mean for you in terms of of
your business because you're you're
saying that potentially you're going to
have to increase the cost past that on
to to customers yeah i mean i've i've
always tried to keep my prices as as low
as i possibly can same as every other
business within stoke on trent to try
and you know
to try and
curve whatever ever increases we get but
i'm i i'm on the side of the food bank
at this this present moment i'm trying
to see how it's going to affect us
in supplying food to even more families
that are going to be struggling um i
don't know i don't know it's going to
pan out how does it work at the moment
with the the food that you you get in
you entirely reliant on donations with
the work that you're doing i'm an
independent food bank so basically i
rely on the people that are on my social
media
and within 24 hours of me asking for any
kind of help the help's usually there
on a daily basis we go out and we supply
food to struggling families vulnerable
families elderly even through the
pandemic we were going to care homes uh
and doing isolation packs
um but again with the increasing and and
energy
um fifty percent higher
it may be
increase so i don't know how then people
are going to cope with with that rise
yeah an already difficult situation
about to be made much more difficult
jason thank you very much for speaking
to us and thank you for the work that
you do for those thank you more
vulnerable thank you
also very busy a few hours ahead today
let's just take a quick look at exactly
what is happening and when
at 11 30 we'll bring you that statement
from the chancellor rishi sunak as he
addresses the comments
then at midday 12 o'clock all eyes on
the bank of england as it gives its
interest rate decision
and at half past 12 we'll hear live from
the bank's governor as he addresses the
details behind any move
this is sky news today coming up
kimberly will bring you up to date with
all the rest of the day's news from the
sky news center
[Music]
first and foremost i think it's the
comfort factor you know and
let's face it the world around us is
slightly messy at the moment i think we
can just find a little oasis in a really
simple joyful word game its rules are
very simple uh we have set the same
challenge
as everybody right across the world
every day
and there's only one we're rationed to
one so i think it's teaching us the
level of patience that you know hasn't
been required of us really for for years
because there's so many apps out there
obviously that offer endless plays of
things so i think it's really special
from that point of view
i know people assume that i'm going to
be a real strategist about this and
there are a lot of people who try and
work out algorithms and things but to be
honest i just um dive straight in
there's probably a little bit of um
of kind of i don't know bargaining i
suppose on my part in that i will go
with one of the most frequently used
letters e always because that's at the
top of the list and i often start with
noise because that includes some of the
most frequently used letters as well um
so you can if you like approach it from
that point of view
but for me the kind of the real pleasure
is in the process of elimination and
that code breaking exercise that comes
after so
you know there's no time pressure as
well you can ponder it all day if you
like and as long as you obey the golden
rule and do not put any spoilers on
twitter or social media because that can
genuinely ruin someone's day
you know i can't i think none of us
could begrudge josh morton for um
wanting a reward from this and also i
think from his statement and from
everything he said so far you know it
seems like it was almost becoming too
much for him it's not something he
expected um and to be fair the new york
times also has real pedigree when it
comes to um word games obviously it has
its crossword um as well which is very
famous so you know hopefully they say
that it will initially be free hopefully
that initial period will uh you know
will be a long one and we can all keep
enjoying it
as much as we do
in afghanistan women and children are
being hit hardest by a devastating and
growing humanitarian crisis
six months on from the taliban takeover
the withdrawal of international aid
means that banks are paralyzed and
teachers and medical staff are going
largely unpaid now the red cross is
warning that hospitals are struggling to
cope and many essential services are
near collapse
our special correspondent alex crawford
reports now from calais now in
bris province and her report contained
some very distressing pictures of a dead
child and babies fighting for their
lives
the women of badgis queue for hours for
free paracetamol for the sick
in afghanistan's most deprived province
nothing comes easy and everything's
scarce
they're cramming babies onto beds in the
province's main hospital in some wards
it's standing room only
a measles outbreak is ripping through
them in the tiny who have already poor
immunity measles can be a death sentence
the insecurities meant vaccines haven't
been given
and there are claims it's the taliban
who prevented them
the talib now in charge of health
services here left school at 14
not long ago he was fighting foreign
troops and he blames others for the
current mess
the previous president was the most
corrupt person in the most corrupt
government in the world he tells us and
we have a lack of everything
that means those least able are losing
this fight
ereza's parents traveled hours to get
help here at the main hospital
but their little daughter died bitingly
cold and aching with hunger
we're living in tents her father says
there's no warm place and that's why she
died we just couldn't keep her warm
there's no time for grief they've two
more children to keep alive
[Music]
there are too many like
perished starving and cold
it never gets any easier
she's already lost two other children
now rizzuma's youngest is only just
clinging to life
cadia has a range of complications
normally treated easily and at the root
of them all is poverty and malnutrition
later the same night after filming this
cadia also succumbed afghanistan's
babies are dying at a shockingly high
rate
[Music]
there's no pain relief for 16 year old
samaya there are few medicines here
which partly explains why the country
has one of the highest maternal and
child mortality rates
it's been a difficult and traumatic
delivery
and the baby is completely limp and
unresponsive
[Music]
i'm really scared the exhausted new
mother says
she's worried for herself and her
newborn son
i'm sorry we're going to break into that
report because we're going to the
commons now where we are going to hear
from the chancellor there he is let's
have a listen 2021 a full year earlier
unemployment was expected to peak at
nearly 12 percent instead it peaked at
5.2 percent and has now fallen to just
over 4
saving more than 2 million jobs and with
the fastest growing economy in the g7
this year over 400 000 more peoples on
payrolls than before the pandemic and
business investment rising it is no
wonder mr speaker that borrowing is set
to fall from 320 billion pounds last
year the highest ever peacetime level to
just 46 billion pounds by the end of
this parliament
as we emerge from the debts of the worst
recession in 300 years we should be
proud of our economic record the economy
is stronger because of the plan we put
in place because of the actions we took
to protect families and businesses and
that plan is working
but for all the progress we are making
the job is not yet done
right now i know that the number one
issue on people's minds is the rising
cost of living
it is the independent bank of england's
role to deliver low and stable inflation
and the governor will set out their
judgments at midday today
and just as the government stood behind
the british people through the pandemic
so we will help people deal with one of
the biggest costs they now face
energy
the energy regulator ofgem
announced this morning that the energy
price cap will rise in april to
1971 pounds an increase of
693 pounds for the average household
without government action
this would be incredibly tough for
millions of hard-working families
so the government is going to step in to
directly help people manage those extra
costs
mr speaker before i set out the steps we
are taking let me explain what is
happening to energy prices and why
people's energy bills are rising
because it is more expensive for
companies who supply our energy to buy
oil coal and gas
of the
693 pound increase in the april price
cap
around 80 percent comes from wholesale
energy prices
over the last year the price of gas
alone has quadrupled
and because over 85 of homes in britain
are heated with a gas boiler
and around 40 percent of our electricity
comes from gas this is hitting
households hard
now the reason gas prices are soaring
are global
across europe and asia a long cold
winter last year depleted gas stores
disruption to other energy sources like
nuclear and wind left us relying more
than usual on gas during the summer
months
surging demand in the world's
manufacturing centres in asia at the
same time as countries like china are
moving away from coal is further
increasing demand for gas
and concerns about a possible russian
incursion into ukraine are putting
further pressure on wholesale gas
markets
and so
prices are rising
mr speaker the price cap has meant that
the impact of soaring gas prices
has so far fallen predominantly on
energy companies so much so that some
suppliers who couldn't afford to meet
those extra costs have gone out of
business as a result
it is not sustainable to keep holding
the price of energy artificially low
for me to stand here and pretend we
don't have to adjust to paying higher
prices would be wrong and dishonest
but what we can do
is take the sting out of a significant
price shock for millions of families by
making sure the increase in prices
is smaller initially and spread over a
longer period
mr speaker without government
intervention the increase in the price
cap
would leave the average household having
to find an extra
693 pounds
the actions i'm announcing today
will provide to the vast majority of
households just over half of that amount
350 pounds
in total the government is going to help
around 28 million households this year
taken together this is a plan to help
with the cost of living worth around 9
billion pounds
we are delivering that support in three
different ways
first we will spread the worst of the
extra costs of this year's energy price
shock over time
this year all domestic electricity
customers will receive an upfront
discount on their bills worth 200 pounds
energy suppliers will apply the discount
on people's bills from october with the
government meeting the cost in full
that discount will automatically be
repaid from people's bills in equal
forty pound installments over the next
five years
this is the right way to support people
while staying on track with our plans to
repair the public finances
and because we are taking a fiscally
responsible approach
we can also provide more help faster to
those who need it most the second part
of our plan
we're going to give people a
150 pound council tax rebate to help
with the cost of energy in april and
this discount won't need to be repaid
and i do want to be clear with the house
that we are deliberately not just giving
support to people on benefits
lots of people on middle incomes are
struggling right now too
[Music]
so we have decided to provide the
council tax rebate to households in
bands a to d
this means around eighty percent of all
homes in england will benefit
and the third part of our plan will
provide local authorities with a
discretionary fund of nearly 150 million
pounds to help those lower income
households who happen to live in higher
council tax properties and households in
bands a to d who are exempt from council
tax at all
we're also confirming today that we'll
go ahead with existing plans to expand
eligibility for the warm homes discount
by almost a third so that three million
vulnerable households will now benefit
from that scheme
and that's not all we're doing to help
vulnerable households
we're providing three billion pounds
over this parliament to help more than
half a million lower income homes become
more energy efficient saving them on
average 290 pounds a year
increasing the national living wage to
nine pounds fifty an hour in april a
rise of over one thousand pounds for two
million low paid workers and we're
providing an effective tax cut for those
on universal credit allowing almost 2
million households to keep an average of
a thousand pounds per year
the payment through energy suppliers
will apply across england wales and
scotland energy policy has devolved in
northern ireland with a different
regulator and the government does not
have the legal powers to intervene but
we will make sure the executive is
funded to do something similar with
around 150 million pounds for northern
ireland through the barnet formula next
year
and because the council tax system is
england only total bonnet consequentials
of around 565 million pounds will be
provided to the devolved administrations
in the usual way
mr speaker i know that some in this
house have argued for a vat cut on
energy
however that policy
would disproportionately benefit
wealthier households
there would be no guarantee that
suppliers would pass on the discounts to
all customers and we should be honest
with ourselves this would become a
permanent government subsidy on
everyone's bills a permanent subsidy
worth two and a half billion pounds
every year at a time when we are trying
to rebuild the public finances
instead our plan
allows us to provide more generous
support
faster to those who need it most
providing 28 million households with at
least 200 pounds and the vast majority
receiving
350 pounds it is fair it is targeted it
is proportionate it is the right way to
help people with a spike in energy costs
mr speaker today's announcements are
just one part of the government's plan
to tackle this country's most pressing
economic challenges
a plan for growth with record investment
in infrastructure innovation and skills
a plan to restore the public finances
with debt falling by the end of this
parliament a plan to cut waiting lists
and back the nhs with 29 billion pounds
over three years and a permanent new
source of funding and with the measures
i've announced today a plan to help with
the rising cost of energy with
pounds more in the pockets of tens of
millions of hard-working families that's
our plan to build a stronger economy not
just today but for the long term and i
commend it to this house
i now call the shutter chancellor rachel
reeves
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
chancellor for his statement
we know have known that this price rise
was coming for months and today we learn
that the energy price cap will increase
to 1
971 pounds in april
in october i called on the government to
provide immediate support for households
cutting vat on their energy bills and
saving 200 pounds of bills with 400
pounds in extra targeted support for
those who need it most which would mean
for some of the poorest families in our
country almost no increase in energy
bills from april the government have not
done that today
now we all remember when the prime
minister said that cutting the
vat was one of the benefits of brexit
he said and i quote when we vote leave
we'll be able to scrap this unfair
and damaging tax
could there ever be a time where this
policy is more needed than it is today
and i would have thought
that the prime minister
with his unblemished record of integrity
would defend the commitments that he has
made but instead it's another pledge
thrown onto the bonfire of broken tory
promises
and the uncomfortable truth for the
chancellor
is that even after what he has announced
today
families in britain will be still paying
hundreds of pounds more for their energy
including some of the poorest families
from april as a result of the
breathtaking rise in energy prices just
announced by often
millions of people cutting back to pay
the bills
citizens advice have said that they have
seen a record number of people in
january struggling with fuel debts
before the energy price increase
but what do the government offer
a buy now pay later scheme that loads up
costs for tomorrow
high prices as far as the eye can see
this year next year and the year after
that give with one hand now and take it
all back later
the party opposite used to talk about
the nation's credit card
well today mr speaker we've seen the
chancellor force british households to
load up their credit cards by lending
billions of pounds to energy companies
the chancellor is gambling that prices
are going to fall
but they could go up further in october
what then
billions more loaded onto people's bills
the best way of targeting support to
those who need it most
would be an increase to 400 pounds and
the extension to 9 million households of
the warm homes discount as labour have
proposed
their scheme today is a pale imitation
of labors especially for the households
and pensioners on the most modest
incomes
the chancellor
instead is using council tax to target
extra help
that will mean many of the poorest
households
will not get extra support while some of
the richest do
and it's people living in the north and
the midlands who will lose out most
the hypocrisy the day after the
government's leveling up white paper is
obvious
mr holden
i think we need to be a little calmer
i'm sure you'll want to catch my eye and
it's not the way to do so
so chancellor rachel reed so can the
chancellor confirm how many people who
are fuel poor will miss out on council
tax support compared to the warm homes
discount support that labor have
announced
mr speaker the government had a choice
only today shel announced that their
profits had quadrupled
to 20 billion dollars
they described their results
as momentous
dividends up profits up and people's
energy bills up too
labour's plan would impose a one-off
windfall tax on those excess profits
but this chancellor would rather shield
the oil and gas producers
while at the same time loading the cost
onto working people and pensioners
[Music]
ministers have described the oil and gas
producers as struggling
struggling mr speaker tell that to the
one in five people who are already
skipping meals so that they can pay
their energy
bills mr speaker
this energy crisis has not happened
overnight
it's a decade of dither and delay from
the party opposite that has brought us
to this point
a decade of failure to regulate our
energy market
a decade in which they have slashed our
gas storage capacity leaving us more
reliant than ever on russia for our gas
imports
a decade of failure to make the most of
solar
tidal and wind energy
and a decade of stalled progress on
insulating our homes to keep bills low
not just for one year but into the
future too
it has been the tory decade that has led
to this announcement mr speaker of the
biggest increase in the price of
domestic energy since records began
that is what the chancellor should
acknowledge and should apologize for
today
the conservatives aren't solving the
cost of living crisis because the
conservative party are the cost of
living crisis
mr
mr speaker
the opposition may have some sound bites
but they certainly don't have a policy
[Applause]
in contrast this government has
announced this government has announced
measures
mr ceiling is there something wrong with
that one you keep knocking because i
think it's in good order you don't need
to test for one worm
jacket
in contrast mr speaker this government
has announced measures to share the
burden with consumers and help manage
the global price rise and despite the
despite the faux outrage from the
bench's opposite i'm sure that even they
would admit privately mr speaker the
support just announced is both generous
and comprehensive
let me uh let me let me take some of the
honorable ladies points in turn mr
speaker well first of all first of all
uh on the topic of v80 can i say mr
speaker how very welcome it is that the
opposition of recognizing the benefits
of brexit
absolutely
i hope they will join me in celebrating
the fact that we have been able to
change
mass migration to this country after
decades that we can create new free
ports in places like t-side that we can
sign new freight free trade deals and we
can deregulate our economy to drive
faster growth uh she talked about vat mr
speaker
what we are vat on average will be worth
90 pounds to every household what we are
doing is providing 150 pounds to those
households who really need it and
delivering that support quicker mr
speaker
mr speaker the honorable lady also tried
to claim that it was the government's
responsibility to manage global gas
prices
it is very clear and any person sensibly
looking at this will acknowledge that
what is causing the increase in gas
prices are global factors
no british government no british
chancellor can change what is happening
in asia or indeed can stop a nuclear
power plant from going offline in
germany and she should acknowledge that
even in places like norway electricity
bills are rising because these are
global factors at play which she would
do well to acknowledge and i know the
ryan ward gentleman sitting next to her
will know that uh having spent a lot of
time on this uh thirdly mr speaker i do
want to i do want to address this point
about
our support for the most vulnerable
because i am proud of this government's
record in supporting those who need our
help the policies that we have announced
today are progressive in their nature a
flat rate will of course mean far more
to those on lower incomes or with lower
energy bills it is worth five times as
much as a percentage of income for those
in the lowest incomes as those on the
highest incomes and she talked about
insulation we are spending over this
parliament three billion pounds to
improve the energy efficiency and
insulation of over half a million
households in fuel poverty mr speaker
that is the right thing to do and it
will save those vulnerable families on
average 300 pounds a year not just this
year but every year going forward and we
have already announced those plans uh mr
speaker and lastly to address her point
on windfall taxes and of course of
course they sound superficially uh
appealing mr speaker but we on this side
of the house deal with complex problems
in a responsible way
[Applause]
now
the obvious the obvious the obvious
impact of a windfall tax would be mr
speaker to deter investment it's as
simple as that and at this moment i want
to see more investments in the naughty
not less
last year mr speaker we saw the lowest
amount of investment on record in the
north sea as my honorable friend pointed
out just yesterday the other day and
there are billions of pounds 11 billion
pounds of projects lined up to go i want
to unlock that investment because that
is good for this country it is good for
british jobs mr speaker and it is good
for our energy security so mr speaker we
will pursue policies that are good for
the interests of this country not just
today but in the future and i know that
my rival friend the energy secretary is
working very hard to make sure that we
have an energy market that is fit for
the future we have made investments in
nuclear which as he rightly pointed out
investments in nuclear that were ignored
by the party opposition
that we are now fixing so in conclusion
mr speaker i am not blind to the
challenges that we face i have to say
though to the honourable member officer
and her colleagues we on this side of
the house did not have the luxury of
sitting on the sidelines and throwing
stones
faced faced with the gravest of crises
this government chose to protect
millions of jobs it chose to support
millions of businesses it chose to
invest in a world-leading vaccination
program and it chose a balanced approach
to covid but so we could open up faster
than anywhere else in europe mr speaker
we did these things at record speed at a
time of great uncertainty
and we will always strive to learn from
mistakes nothing is ever perfect when
responding to a crisis but i'd say to
the party opposite there is a fine line
between reasonable criticism and
political opportunism
and in my and in my
and in my experience mr speaker the
british people can always tell the
difference
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i welcome my
rightful friends announcement today
does he agree that a cut in vit to solve
this crisis a completely flawed policy
absolutely as evidenced by the three
economists who spoke to the treasury
select committee this week including
torsten bell from the resolution
foundation who wanted something far more
targeted such as my writer my friend has
announced today
it is clear one factor in this crisis is
russia's willingness to weaponize its
gas supplies
will he confirm if there is any
incursion into the ukraine that this
country and other international
countries
will look at weaponizing our banking
system
which would be economically catastrophic
for russia should they do that
chancellor mr speaker i thank honorable
fenn for his uh question
on the point of vit uh you know nothing
further to add and he's right that what
we are doing is more targeted it is
faster and it is more generous to those
who need our help uh and i can assure
him that with regard to sanctions on
russia absolutely nothing is off the
table and we are we are working very
closely with our international partners
as a foreign secretary as outlined to
prepare a very robust package of
sanctions smp spokesperson alum
thank you mr speaker the chancellor
brags about having the fastest recovery
but that's actually wrong because italy
for a start's got a higher growth rate
but if the economy is doing so well why
is he still introducing 12 billion uh
tax on workers um this financial year
why is it taken to the last minute to
try and do something about the cost of
living crisis and then why is so much of
this actually alone that bill peers are
going to pay back he talks about not
doing a vat cut because he wants a more
targeted approach so how is governor
rebate a targeted approach it's
illogical
now mr speaker as the treasurer is
currently raking and compared to where
they thought they'd be in the march 2021
budget an extra three billion pounds
this financial year next year from oil
gas revenues vat receipt productions in
october last year was nearly 40 billion
pounds higher than what they were
for uh march 2021 such a lot of money
the threat could be freeing up meanwhile
average energy bills increased airlast
this year to nearly 1200 pounds up from
700 pounds a year before bringing an
extra 0.6 billion in far
the vat increased due to the cut rise is
going to bring the treasure another 8.8
million pounds a year so so much more
money that could free up the scottish
government's bringing in the 20 pounds
per week child payment and then
operating the child winter assistance
payment so could the chance or not look
at doing something similar will it
confirm that the council tax er rebate
proposal is bringing in or havana
consequentials how much help be and that
that will go to scottish government well
they look at devolving further budgets
and powers so that scotland can do a
more targeted approach now national
energy action estimated that the
increase in the cap would put six
million people into fuel poverty so with
his measures what impact assessments
government made and how many households
have been fuel poverty how many more
premature deaths will they be because
people in f fuel poverty
and lastly mr speaker in the highlands
of scotland the highlands generate
electricity and send it to the rest of
the uk but yet users help us using the
highlands and the restricted meters pay
for pencil unit warfare electricity 400
pounds more on their bills when will the
treasury and bees support the thor gem
to remove that ridiculous surcharge for
raising people in the high arms yeah
either
mr speaker i'm uh
i'm happy
mr speaker i'm happy to uh to confirm to
the honourable gentleman that the barnet
consequentials for scotland will be
around 290 million pounds which i hope
that uh he will welcome and my
honourable friend the chief secretary
speaking to kate forbes later today to
go over the details and i very much hope
that the scottish government will choose
to do something very similar to what we
are doing to the benefit of scottish
citizens of course scottish citizens
will benefit from the rebate scheme on
bills because that is a gb wide policy
uh as i outlined and with regard to his
broader points on
the north sea i i said that there is a
clear point of difference i think
between us on this side of the house and
the smp because we believe in the future
of the north sea we believe in the oil
and gas industry we believe in those 200
000 jobs that it supports and we want to
make sure it plays a important part of
our transition to net zero mr speaker uh
and i i hope that he can see that that
is the right thing for scotland and will
join us in supporting that very
important industry
[Music]
particularly it's thoughtful and
progressive nature that of the actions
that he plans to take does he agree with
me that it is right to help not only the
poorest but also those on middle incomes
who are struggling with their household
budgets absolutely
no my honourable friend is absolutely
right and i know this is something that
she has pressed me on behalf of her
constituents
a price increase of this magnitude
impacts almost everybody mr speaker and
it is right that our response therefore
helps almost everybody that's what we
are doing making sure that those
families that are working hard on
household incomes and 40 000 or so will
still get the 150 pounds worth of
support four out of every households
will benefit we are on the side of
hard-working families like that mr
speaker and i make no apology for it
thank you
thank you mr
mr speaker i see we now have the clarner
chancellor the pain now buy now give get
it now and pay later but there is a
really important issue about council tax
when areas like mine and parts of london
there are not many people in bands
certainly bans a to c but who is going
to fund the council tax rebate will that
be fully funded by the exchequer and
will there be a weighting of 150 million
pound fund to the areas like mine where
i've got poor households in high value
properties
mr speaker just to confirm for the
honourable lady it's council tax bans a
to d so it is four out of every five
five households across england obviously
that will vary by region uh i can
confirm to how that will be fully
exchequer funded and on top of that
there will be a discretionary fund of
around 150 million pounds uh which the
department for local government will
decide the best allocation formula for
and that will be able to be used by
local authorities to help those
low-income households who happen to live
in higher council tax ban properties and
indeed those people
students for example that are exempt
from paying council tax at all but we
would want to get the support to though
thank you mr speaker conservatives
believe
in holding taxes down
and putting more money
in that people's pockets and so they can
decide how to spend it socialists
believe in raising taxes and then
choosing to give it back in the form of
discounts from rebates to selected
people the government think need it
could the chancellor tell me his
approach
in increasing national insurance
contributions and then handing money
back to different people through
rebates and discounts is that a
conservative approach or a socialist
approach
well
mr speaker with the greatest respect for
honourable friend i also believe that it
is a conservative approach to be
responsible with this nation's public
finances
i believe after recovering from the
worst economic shock in 300 years we're
borrowing spiral to levels that we have
not seen since world war ii that it is
right and responsible to tackle that and
get our borrowing and debt down to
sustainable levels which is why i've had
to make difficult decisions but also to
fund the country's number one priority
the nhs and an unacceptably high growing
number of people waiting for operations
that's all that funding will do it's
right that we provide a secure long-term
sustainable funding stream for the
country's number one priority and they
should be reassured that every penny of
that levy is going to go to the thing
that they care most about stephen tips
thank you mr speaker
um the
the there's an obvious unfairness in the
massive profits being made by the oil
and gas companies at a time when
families are facing such great hardship
surely the chancellor must make an
intervention to
address that
and
he's announced a discretionary fund for
local councils worried families will
have no idea how much that will benefit
them if at all will he instead
introduce an uplift in universal credit
having cut universal credit so unfairly
just four months ago
mr speaker it's worth pointing out that
the energy companies that he talks about
already are subject to a far higher rate
of corporation tax in fact double the
rate of corporation tax that other
companies pay 40 versus currently uh 19
and i won't repeat my arguments about
the windfall tax that i made earlier and
no mr speaker we believe the right way
is to keep make sure that people can
keep more of what they earn which is why
we cut the universal credit taper rate
by eight percentage points that's a 2.2
billion pound tax cut it will benefit
two million of the lowest paid people in
our society it's making work pay it's
strengthening incentives to work it's
the right policy it's a conservative
policy esther might be
mr speaker
many families across the country will
struggle with their energy bills this
year so i am grateful that we have a
chance lose in touch with that
will he commit
to continue to ensure those in middle
britain are supported by this government
as well as those on the very lowest of
incomes
my writable friend is absolutely right
and i can give her that reassurance and
hopefully today's announcements will
provide her with the confidence she
needs that both i and this government
are committed to being on the side of
those hard-working families which i know
does she does an enormous amount to
represent and champion in this house
lawrence ishalami
thank you mr dr speaker the chancellor
mentioned that energy suppliers will
apply the discount on people's bills
from october
i'm contacted by vauxhall constituents
on an almost daily basis
residents living in properties that are
too cold to heat residents pleading with
me to help them get those repairs done
current data suggests that over 8 000
households in vauxhall already living in
fuel poverty now
mr deputy speaker so what does the
chancellor have to say to my
constituents who already unable to make
ends meet now
and who are facing a hike of over 700
pounds in their energy bills
mr deputy speaker what i can tell them
is they won't have to wait until october
as the party opposites proposals would
have had them do they will receive 150
pounds in april mr speaker
and then in october and in october they
will receive the rebate on their bills
at a time when the energy price cap will
also be looked at again so it'll be
appropriate that there is further action
to support them but this is why this
policy is the right policy by using the
council tax system we can get money to
people faster mr deputy speaker 150
pounds in april for her constituents
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
can i welcome this smart set of measures
because we must retain fiscal discipline
because otherwise the problem will get
worse rather than better but could i
also ask a question about monetary
policy which the chancellor mentioned
he mentioned the independence of the
bank of england decision which has just
been announced but there's some chatter
about working in tandem with the bank so
can he confirm that in monetary policy
not just in interest rate setting but in
with the withdrawal of qe that bank
independence will be respected
[Music]
i can give my wrong friend that
assurance it is absolutely right and
proper that the bank is independent of
government on matters of monetary policy
that is exactly uh what has always been
the case over the last two years and
will continue to be the case and i can
wholeheartedly give him that assurance
nick smith
thank you mr deputy speaker the
chancellor will be pleased that his
campaign team are behind him today
does he really think that the super
profits of 20 billion dollars
made by shell are untouchable
his hands-off approach won't persuade
many people across our country
well mr deputy speaker i think what
millions of people across this country
will see today is a government that is
on their side yeah
it is a government that is taking action
to help them with the anxiety they feel
about rising energy bills it is doing it
in a proportionate fair and targeted way
and it is doing it in a responsible way
to protect them not just today but for
years into the future as well
robert buckland thank you mr deputy
speaker thousands of families in swindon
and millions of households across the
country will welcome the immediate help
on council tax that he has announced
today in his very welcome statement does
he agree with me that the uh the cod
analysis that we heard from the right
honourable lady opposite about the
energy market in europe is really a
demonstrable evidence of the paucity of
the party opposites uh approach to
energy it isn't our approach to
a zero-carbon economy but based upon
energy security going to be the way that
we deliver uh our country out of these
short-term problems
well my uh vulnerable friend makes as
ever an excellent point he's absolutely
right i agree wholeheartedly with him
and and he will know my vulnerable
friend the energy secretary is working
very hard to undo some of the mistakes
that the party opposite made in the
past chris bryant thank you mr deputy
speaker i know the chances all pumped up
but this is this is pretty puny stuff to
be honest 350
350 pounds isn't going
350 pounds isn't going to touch the
sides of the problem for my constituents
in the room
gas and electricity up for the average
family in my constituency by 686 pounds
fuel up by 314 pounds the average weekly
shop up by 385 pounds universal credit
cut by 1040 pounds national insurance up
by 150 and frozen tax allowances by him
will cost another 300 pounds that's 2
875 pounds in a constituency where the
average wage is 27 000 pounds
that is really going to cause hardship
350 pounds doesn't even touch it
[Applause]
mr deputy speaker
the party opposite have proposals which
would give considerably less to many
people so it's a bit rich to hear that
but he he had a long list of numbers mr
deputy speaker i also have a long list
of numbers 400 000 more people on
payroll than there were before the
crisis two million jobs saved because of
the actions of this government the
national living wage going up by a
thousand pounds a year in april and a
thousand pound tax cut for millions of
people on universal credit those are
what we are doing mr speaker to put more
money into people's pockets when they
need it and they can rely on us to
continue supporting them not just now
but for days and years into the future
[Applause]
well welcome uh good afternoon we'll
leave the comments for a second there
you join me live in stoke on trent where
millions of people here and right across
the country have just been told their
energy bills are set to rise
significantly we'll bring you more on
that in just a moment but let's bring
you some breaking news now the bank of
england has just announced the latest
decision to raise interest rates that's
from 0.25 to 0.5
let's go straight to the bank of england
and speak to our economics and data
editor ed conway ed
yeah thanks julian i mean this is a big
moment for the uk economy because as
well as having energy prices uh
increasing we've had that confirmation
from off gem as well as having some
intervention uh from the government to
try and deal with that we also have news
that the bank of england well two things
really the bank of england has raised
interest rates uh from 0.25 percent to
0.5 percent it could have been more four
members of the monetary policy committee
were arguing for a half point increase
so they would have gone up to 0.75
percent just to give you a sense that
they really are concerned about the rise
in inflation they forecast that
inflation is going to go above
7
this spring it's the highest level since
1991 but here is the most striking thing
really when you look within their latest
forecast because they've just released
their latest forecast for the state of
the economy when you look at all of
these things put together so the rise in
energy prices when you look at the rise
in taxes the tax burden very high at the
moment when you look at how weak
earnings are compared with inflation
you're seeing the biggest fall in
disposable incomes so you're talking
about post-tax labor income that's the
name of the series the biggest fall in
that series that we've ever seen as far
back as the records go they go to 1990
they are falling those labor income
disposable incomes they are falling by
two percent this year according to the
bank's forecast we've never seen
anything like that and it just
underlines what a cost of living crisis
we're facing at the moment the bank
talking about that talking about
inflation but saying that the risk of
higher inflation is so great that even
though this is going to cause more pain
for families particularly those on
floating rate mortgages not many people
but nonetheless some people they are
deciding nonetheless to raise interest
rates so a very big moment for the uk
economy uh given that just what they're
seeing out there uh the state of the
economy too and i should say i mean
normally in any other day this would be
a big story but they've also cut their
growth forecast by a significant amount
as well so put it all together and it
really is a striking moment it really
feels like the moment that the cost of
living crisis has become
a living reality for many people for
millions of people around the uh the
country and the bank of england
underlining that we really haven't seen
anything like this for a long time
ed for the moment thank you as you say
uh quite a few financial stories uh
bidding for the the headlines uh today
very busy day but let's take you
straight back to the house of commons
where uh is still speaking and make sure
the government continues to cut the cost
living for hard-working
families i uh i'm very grateful to my
honourable friend for his his support
and he rightly champions those people
who are just about managing who are
working incredibly hard to build a
better life for them and their families
and they should know that this
government is on their side thank you
very much mr speaker for his support
because we will continue to champion
them christine jardine
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
these plans are playing russian roulette
with taxpayers money gambling that
prices will go down
rather than providing a real solution to
help families avoid skyrocketing bills
it's just delaying the pain while
increasing taxes by 600 pounds a year
for the average household so why won't
you listen
to our suggestions for a package that
would actually help families reduce
their bills by a thousand pounds a year
surely it's time to admit
he's got it wrong
it's time to scrap the conservative tax
hikes
mr speaker what we haven't heard from
the party is any plan to provide the
funding that the nhs needs right
we all know that the nhs is grappling
with recovering from covid there's an
unprecedented scale of backlogs to work
through that and social care system that
needs urgent reform the only way to
grapple with those challenges is to
provide the nhs and social care with a
sustainable source of funding that's
what we are doing it is the responsible
and right approach it is a progressive
approach and it will benefit people in
scotland wales and northern london as
well as england and in the long run it
will be the right thing for this country
alan cairns thank you mr deputy speaker
can i congratulate my red honourable
friend for the comprehensive package of
support that he's provided both fiscally
responsible in the face of the uh energy
uh
volatility uh globally uh my
constituents will have the benefit and
the reassurance of the rebate that he's
announced on energy bills but they won't
have the reassurance of the council tax
support that he's making available in
england will he therefore
at least encourage the welsh government
to follow suit so my constituents have
the same benefit in england or even take
it a step further and insist that the
benefit is passed on
uh i thank my vulnerable friend i can
confirm that the uh welsh administration
will receive 175 million pounds or so in
barnet consequentials which will enable
them to provide the similar discount and
uh my vulnerable friend the chief
secretary will be speaking to the welsh
government later today and he will very
much make the point that we would like
to see that to the benefit of all of his
constituents and those across wales
like vets
thank you mr deputy speaker in terms of
the council tax rebate there are some of
the poorest families who
don't pay
a significant amount of council tax
because they're on council tax support
schemes will they still get even if
their council tax bills are less than
150 pounds a year the full 150 pounds
will that therefore be paid in cash to
them
by the local authority in april and in
terms of the 150 million pounds
discretionary fund will it be truly
discretionary for councils to decide how
they spend it or the government going to
direct how it's spent
mr deputy speaker of course the uh
honorable gentleman is well informed on
these issues uh our intention is that
those people do benefit from the 150
pounds and that's why we are providing
the discretionary fund it's been sized
with a sense of who those people are and
how many they are we will of course
provide some guidance to local
authorities about who we would expect
the support to go to but ultimately they
will be able to make those decisions for
themselves john penrose
mr deputy speaker can i um thank the
chancellor for an extremely welcome
package and it's uh it's the latest step
i think in a series of very strong
reactions to different crises throughout
the pandemic and now today
he also mentioned improving the
investment in north sea or north sea um
gastfield which is very well yeah
but it is only a temporary set of issues
it's only a temporary set of solutions
which will dull the initial economic
pain without solving the long-term
problem of sky-high energy prices what
conversations he therefore had with his
colleagues sitting next to him the
energy secretary about solutions to deal
with those longer-term problems and when
can we expect to hear answers to those
things to do with
reforming the price cap performing the
wholesale energy market and the like
yeah well my uh honorable friend is very
thoughtful on these matters and he's
long made this point and he's right to
make this point that we must also make
sure that the long-term energy market is
working uh in all our benefit i can't
tell him that both the energy sector
myself and the prime minister have been
involved in these conversations for
quite some time uh the energy secretary
is working on a set of measures which
will address i think many of his
concerns and he should expect to hear
from the government soon alex davis
jones thank you mr deputy speaker can i
just say how nice it is to see the
chancellor finding this place i know
some of us have been considering filing
a missing person's report but uh given
his absence in the recent weeks and
whilst i appreciate his update for
families across ponte pries and taffy is
just another case of too little too late
the welsh labour government have doubled
the warm home discount scheme and
labour's proposal would have taken 600
pound off the bills for the poorest in
our country the chancellor's plan gives
them 350 pounds off why is this fallen
so far short of what is needed and what
is
proposed well mr deputy speaker i'm
sorry that she didn't welcome the 175
million pounds and barnet consequentials
for the welsh administration uh but also
this government is providing support
significant support to those on middle
incomes because they are also struggling
mr speaker and we believe that is the
right approach bob seeley very much
indeed mr deputy speaker i welcome very
much the chancellor's recognition as our
honourable friend was saying of the
importance of a long-term energy policy
and also thank you very much indeed face
up for council taxpayers the atd ban
will cover most folks on the island
can he just confirm to me that he's
talking about people with primary
residences both on the island but also
nationally thank you yes uh my uh
honorable friend makes an excellent
point and i can confirm that that 150
pounds is not for those with either
second homes or empty homes and we'll
make that crystal clear in how the
policy is executed jim shannon thank
uh debbie speaker first of all can i
thank the chancellor for for his culture
it's not to be charlie said there's a
bit of money it's been set aside we
appreciate that but with this further
right of energy along with the uplifted
cost of living in general we are looking
at working families choosing what to cut
out of their lives to make ends meet
well i very much welcome the news and
put it on record the 150 150 million for
northern ireland and also the other
barnet consequentials that will come
along as well
could i ask chance to answer this
question would he consider and commit to
reviewing the child benefit threshold
for families whose wages are the same
and yet it simply isn't worth the same
in real money terms as it did when the
threshold was introduced in 2013. thank
you very
i'm grateful to the uh honorable
gentleman uh for his question and i'm
glad he recognizes there are two sets of
bonnet consequences for northern ireland
stemming from each of the two policies
which some total 250 million pounds he
will appreciate i can't comment on
future tax and welfare policy but as
always i will uh take what he says and
reflect on it
jonathan gullitz thank you mr deputy
speaker and i warmly welcome the
chancellor's statement because of 94
percent of properties in stoke-on-trent
our council tax band a to c so therefore
this 150 pound rebate is going to do
wonders across stoke-on-trent north kids
grove and torque but on his recent visit
to the city of stoke-on-trent he knows
that the ceramic sector is an
energy-intensive industry and is going
to be looking for some more creative
solutions in the short term to help them
with rising energy costs couldn't he
confirm that he will meet with me and
the other stoke-on-trent mps to discuss
his ideas further
mr deputy speaker i'm always happy to
meet with my uh honourable friends from
stoke which benefited from not just one
not just two but three uh successful
leveling up fun bids uh which i was
pleased to visit recently uh he's right
and he's a proper champion for the
ceramic sector in this house rightly i
always enjoyed meeting representatives
from that sector on my recent visit i'll
be happy to meet with him and then to
discuss the situation further paris
sherman
mr deputy speaker we all know that the
uh chancellor is a fast-talking slick
operator who knows how to get head down
when it's useful
because i tell him that someone who's
been in this house since 1979
he's the most incompetent chancellor
i've ever seen
and when children go to bed
when children
he doesn't like him mrs people when
children in my constituency go to bed
with no food in their tummies with no
heat in their homes
what does he really think is the
honorable position of a chancellor who
has just allowed one of his policies
directly to be taken in fraud 4.3
billion pounds of fraud under his watch
any other chancellor that i've known
would come to the house today to resign
[Applause]
mr speaker i'll let this government's
record on economic policy speak for
itself it's a record i'm proud of um but
i can provide uh the honourable
gentleman with reassurance that i and
the government remain committed to
tackling fraud wherever we see it uh he
mentions a figure uh in 4.9 billion
pounds as i mentioned to the house in
orals on tuesday that estimate has
already been reduced mr speaker by a
third uh by 1.6 billion because of the
actions we are taking i won't go into
the mall now but he should know that we
will go after everyone wherever we can
to recover that money for the taxpayer
and i'm confident that we will do a very
good job
thank you mr deputy speaker this is a
targeted package that helps those just
about managing which is entirely right
but mr deputy speaker under the last
labour government the party opposite
closed six nuclear power stations and
had a policy of no new nuclear does he
agree with me that alongside these
messages these measures to help people
in the short term it's imperative that
we invest in our long-term energy
security in domestic gas production in
renewables and crucially in new nuclear
yeah
my honourable friend is absolutely right
about some of the failures of policy
that the party opposite propagated in
power that is being fixed by honourable
friend the energy secretary we are not
just investing in new nuclear as he said
with billions of pounds at the spending
review but also in offshore wind and as
he knows in his part of the world carbon
capture and storage and hydrogen where
t-side is playing a starring role in
that green energy revolution
the chancellor will be aware that nearly
20 percent of households in wales are
not connected to the maine's gas grid in
rural areas like keradigi on that figure
actually rises to over 80 percent and
research by the office of national
statistics notes that kennedy guns are
for the highest increase in fuel bills
of any air okay we're leaving the
commons we're going straight to
piccadilly in london the bafta
nominations are being announced
and tom allen there they're um
announcing the best direct nomination so
let's have a listen
belfast
don't look up
june
licorice pizza
the power of the dog
and finally these are the six most
nominated films of this year oh i mean
wow
amazing i'll be very happy june have
done amazingly well yeah i love their
shoes
and congratulations to all of our
brilliant nominees they are absolutely
amazing very inspiring congratulations
what a great bunch this year genuinely
really really brilliant now please tune
in on sunday the 13th of march to watch
all the action from the ee bafta film
awards hosted by rebel wilson
oh i can't wait the ceremony will be
broadcast on bbc one in the uk and
throughout the world with live coverage
of the red carpet on baptist social
media channels hosted by myself adria
dudu and himself tom allen
yes that's right liz again yeah you
can't get enough of a good thing am i
right ah you are so right we are very
moorish aren't we
like lovely crisps
pass me a few bags
you can use the hashtag ee baftas to
start your chin racking no oh i love a
chin wag me too you've got so many of
them
[Applause]
let's go to that buffet let's do it
thank you very much
bye
okay so there you had it the nominations
um
for
the baftas
they just announced um that was ajo juju
and tom allen of course um they just
announced the nomination for best film
hang on a second let me get it up
so um nomination for best film of course
as soon as i come i i had it here and
then as soon as you come back it's not
up okay i'm just going to tell you a bit
more about it they're taking place on
march the 22nd
rebel wilson is going to be hosting it
of course last year it wasn't in person
this year it is going to be in person so
they're really trying to get people um
back in best film nominees belfast have
you seen that it's meant to be brilliant
uh don't look up i have seen that that
is brilliant
june licorice pizza and the power of the
dog okay right let's go to our arts and
entertainment gross bonner katy spencer
she knows a bit more about this than i
do
katie take us through the door
just a bit more take us through the
nominations katie
well i have to say that was a bit of an
upset there's certainly some notable
names that are missing from that list
and certainly some exciting additions as
well um shall we take you i think you
you only came in at the end so should we
take a look back through um some of the
awards that were mentioned the most
unexpected thing we have to talk about
june obviously this this big sci-fi
blockbuster leading the way uh with 11
nominations so for the best picture um
certainly there were three names that we
expected that have made the list uh this
year power of the dog benedict
cumberbatch's um toxic masculinity uh
film that's made the list licorice pizza
everyone has been raving about
critically as well that made the list um
belfast kenneth brenner's uh
semi-autobiographical take on his
childhood also on the list but the
upsets on here that we weren't expecting
june obviously 11 nominations up for
best picture i think if people were
thinking a blockbuster was going to be
on the list we were expecting it to be
um james bond no time to die uh but yes
so that's that's my best picture don't
look up as well uh that's uh adam
mckay's satire on the climate crisis
again critically people have loved these
but i think perhaps it is quite
unexpected that it's name it's made the
best picture list um for best director
three of the women on this list it split
three three three men three women which
is extraordinary normally in other years
we sort of
make a big thing of the fact that
there's hardly any women that ever seem
to qualify three of the women on this
list
have made it for best director happening
audrey duran uh the power of the dog
jane campion titan julia dicorno i mean
that that's the inclusion of that is
quite amusing it's about a woman who has
a fetish for cars i think really of that
category jane campion the filmmaker
who's been around for decades now we're
expecting her to be
certainly one of the front runners for
that if we take you through leading
actress i mean the big snub there
everyone i think was expecting kristen
stewart for playing princess diana in
spencer to be nominated nothing for her
on this lady gaga who of course got a
lot of stick for her italian accent in
house of gucci she's made the the cut
here as has alana heim for licorice
pizza obviously she's from a music
background this is her first uh go at
acting in films extraordinary
performance she gets in that i think
people will be very excited to see that
koda coders emilia jones uh makes the
list for this is a brilliant indie film
that was bought for millions at the
sundance film festival about uh the
child of a
deaf family who it's a coming-of-age
tale but it's a great film but perhaps
an unexpected name really to make it on
that list leading actor
we were talking a bit earlier today
about the fact that we were all
expecting denzel washington to be uh
named on there for uh macbeth sadly i
mean he hasn't ever been nominated for a
bafta he hasn't this year been nominated
for a bafta either so he's one of the
notable uh exceptions really on this
leading actor list will smith though who
also hasn't been nominated uh for a
bafta before he has made the list uh for
king richard playing the the father of
venus and serena williams in that role
benedict cumberbatch i think uh i mean
it's a good year for british names as
well benedict cumberbatch as a brit
obviously a deal actor and you've got
stephen graham on there as well i mean a
deal actor
it's brilliant he won a few weeks ago at
the the independent film awards i think
people after that were noticing the film
and talking about it a lot more but it
is nevertheless very unexpected that
he's made it in the leading actor
character category you would think
perhaps
his addition in this list means that
denzel probably got uh elbowed out the
way but it it is a great film alien ava
uh and if we just take you through the
tallies of who won what june
comes away with the most nominations of
11 power of the dog has scored eight
nominations and belfast only six i think
we were expecting uh certainly that uh
sir kenneth branagh would be nominated
for best director he in fact has only
been nominated for screenplay this year
but um what a shocker of june it's this
big epic sci-fi big budget uh one of the
biggest openings that warner brothers
had last year and i just think
that might say something of really the
world we were in last year post pandemic
people were very excited to watch that
film did tremendously well at the the
box office and certainly this year at
the baftas we feel that that's reflected
really these big book busters are
nominated and we're seeing that
reflected in the nominations
okay katie um thank you so much i don't
know if i'm more upset about jamie
dornan not getting a nomination or
denzel
but um
yeah thanks a lot katie
hello there welcome back to stoke on
trent i've relocated inside to the
unicorn in it is a pub but i'm not here
to drink i'm here to speak to uh tracy
bowen um
not a happy subject uh although this is
a place where many people come to to
drown their sorrows um tell us the
implications of the
price hike today in terms of energy
prices going up to 1 900 plus
a year yeah well it's quite worrying
really isn't it i mean just before
christmas my energy provider went um and
ceased it trading so we had to go with
somebody else we tacked it quite a bit
over christmas anyway
um
it's worrying i mean hospitality's been
hit hard and you know we've just started
to recover a bit and then we've got
these added costs
um with this pub we have to have the
heating on to keep the customers warm
but we've also got to make sure we've
got doors open for ventilation
um what we've covered still being
prevalent around the area and stuff so
just customer confidence and keeping
them warm as well yeah so how does it
operate now because you've got to
increase uh ventilation haven't you yeah
once i start getting quite a few
customers in it starts getting a bit
uncomfortable in here because it gets so
small so we have to open the back door
um keeps the ventilation going um but of
course we've still got to keep the
heating on to keep them warm so it's
basically you're throwing money down the
drain really but it's just something
that you've got to do you know at the
moment well these colder months
and for you personally what does it mean
at home because it's a huge hike isn't
it yeah yeah it's difficult um my
apartment's all electric so you know
storage heaters are known to be
expensive anyway um i've just gone to
putting blankets and things you know um
instead of putting eating on all the
time
when people come into the pub as i said
at the the start often to drown their
their their sorrows sometimes to
celebrate it it's for a good good reason
what's the conversation been like how
has it it changed over you know what
people talk about when they come in here
yeah well the conversation's obviously
changed from covid now now more people
are coming back out um and they are
concerned about the energy prices you
know the wages and stoke-on-trent as
well are quite low you know obviously
we've got the minimum wage but it's not
much above them
um so yeah
they're concerned
in terms of the area we know that about
25 000
are in the um
poverty trap or considered poverty fuel
trap
overall how is that going to affect
the area
um i think it's going to hit it hard i
think fewer people are going to come out
you know where
we've got a theater locally and you know
people travel to it but i think people
that live locally you know aren't going
to be coming out and doing things you
know and
hopefully you know that people still
come to the pub and you know socialize
because that's it yeah i think they can
keep warm here so yes
that's a that's a good plus tracy thanks
very much for speaking to us thank you
so much i want to take you now to a bank
of england uh press conference news
conference let's uh listen into that
as this monetary policy report went to
press
sterling oil prices were almost 90
percent above their levels at the end of
2020.
uk wholesale gas prices were almost 400
percent higher
wholesale electricity prices had risen
by more than 300 percent
the uk is a net importer of energy and
tradable goods
and the rise in global prices will
inevitably both put upward pressure on
inflation
and weigh on uk real income and spending
beyond the near term and conditioned on
a market implied path for bank rates
that rises to around one and a half
percent by the middle of next year
uk gdp growth is expected to slow to
subdued rates
a small margin of spare capacity is
likely to emerge later this year
and then to build over the forecast
period
in the labor market unemployment has
continued to fall despite the closure of
the furlough scheme
according to the labour force survey the
unemployment rate reached 4.1 in the
three months to november
demand for workers remains robust
with job churn elevated and the number
of vacancies
at a record high
unemployment is projected to fall a
little further over the coming months
before rising again owing to the impact
of higher global energy and tradeable
goods prices on domestic demand
reflecting the tight labour market pay
growth is somewhat above pre-pandemic
rates at around four percent
and respondents to the bank's agents and
your pay survey expect pay settlements
to increase this year
in the monetary policy committee's
central projection
underlying pay growth is expected to
rise to around four and three quarter
percent over the coming year
before falling to around two and a half
percent over the medium term
as labor market conditions ease
to inflation uk consumer price inflation
rose to 5.4 in december
well above its 2 target
and almost 1 percentage point higher
than expected at the time of the
november monetary policy report
most of the overshoot inflation relative
to the target
continues to reflect the more general
rise in the price of globally traded
goods
higher energy prices explain nearly one
percentage point of the rise in
inflation since september
but rising domestic cost pressures
driven by a tight labor market have also
added to the upward pressure on consumer
prices
albeit to a lesser extent
core inflation which strips out energy
and other volatile items
picked up to 4.2 percent in december
inflation is expected to increase
further in the coming months peaking at
around seven and a quarter percent in
april when higher utility price caps are
due to be implemented
in the central projection the upward
pressure on cpi inflation dissipates
over time
however as global energy prices stop
rising
and global supply constraints stabilize
while domestic cost pressures ease with
demand weakening
the widening degree of spare capacity
adds further to the downward pressure on
inflation in the second half of the
forecast
conditional on the market implied path
for bank rate
consumer price inflation is projected to
fall
to a little above the two percent target
in two years time
and below the target by a greater margin
in three years
in line with the usual convention the
committee's forecast is conditioned on
announced government policy
now i should note that the committee's
forecast was closed before offgem's
announcement on the level of the energy
price cap
and the government's announcement of its
policy response this morning
so the impact of these announcements is
not included in the projection presented
in the monetary policy report
it's unlikely that the policies will
have a material impact on consumer price
inflation beyond the second year of the
forecast
though we obviously will need to discuss
carefully with the ons how these various
announcements are going to be treated
let me turn to the risks around the
outlook
the degree of uncertainty around the
outlook remains unusually high
looking over the near term upside risks
to inflation are in full focus
in the monetary policy committee's
central projection
wage growth moderates as domestic demand
weakens owing to the squeeze in real
incomes from higher energy and tradable
goods prices
over the past few months however
indicators of short-term inflation
expectations have risen as inflation
itself has picked up
the bank's agent survey
captures a pickup in expected pay
settlements driven by higher consumer
price inflation in addition to labour
market tightness
some firms report to us that they have
started passing on higher labor costs to
consumer prices
if these effects prove stronger or more
persistent
than assumed in the central projection
inflation could rise further
the mpc will continue to monitor
indicators of expectations and their
impact very closely
but as inflation comes down over the
medium term downside risks come into
sharper focus
the committee's forecast is conditioned
on parts of oil gas and electricity
prices
that follow their respective futures
curves for the first six months
and beyond that
given the inherent unpredictability of
these prices remain constant
given the shape of the futures
curves this assumption implies that
beyond that six month horizon
the assumed paths of wholesale energy
prices remain a long way above the
levels that markets expect currently
if energy prices were to fall back to
the levels employed by futures curves
the degree of excess supply and
unemployment would be around half a
percentage point lower by the end of the
forecast period
cpi inflation would fall towards target
more rapidly
and conditional on the current market
implied path for bank rate would be
around three quarters of a percentage
point below the target in two and in
three years time
let me turn now to the immediate
monetary policy decision
the monthly policy committee's agreement
is clear
that the inflation target applies at all
times
reflecting the primacy of the monetary
policy's price stability objective
the remit also recognises that there
will be occasions when inflation departs
from the target as a result of shocks
and disturbances
in the recent unprecedented
circumstances the economy has been
subject to very large and repeated
shocks
the continued sharp rises in global
energy and tradeable goods prices will
necessarily both put upward pressure on
inflation and weigh on uk real aggregate
income and spending
monetary policy is unable to prevent us
the role of monetary policy is to ensure
that as the economy adapts to this shock
to real incomes
it does so in a way that is consistent
with consumer price inflation returning
sustainably to the two percent target in
the medium term
while minimizing undesirable volatility
in output
given the current tightness of the
labour market and continuing signs of
greater persistence in domestic cost and
price pressures
the committee judges that an increase in
bank rate of 0.25 percentage points is
warranted at this meeting
consistent with the mpc's existing
guidance from the august 2021 monetary
policy report
the committee agreed at this meeting
that the bank of england should cease to
reinvest maturities falling due from its
stock of uk government bond purchases
the committee further agreed that the
bank of england should start to unwind
its stock of sterling non-financial
investment great corporate bonds
let me finish with some thoughts on the
future
this is not a standard demand driven
rise in bank rate
the predominant cause of higher
inflation is an extreme example of what
economists describe as a terms of trade
shock
import prices
in particular those of energy and traded
goods have risen very significantly
this raises the cost of living for all
of us and reduces real national income
we have not raised interest rates today
because the economy is roaring away
the economy is only now back to the size
it was immediately before the pandemic a
couple of years ago
an increase in bank rate is necessary
because it is unlikely that inflation
will return to target without it
we face the risk that some of the higher
imported inflation could become
ingrained within the domestic economy
leading to a longer period of high
inflation
given the uncertainties however it
should be no surprise that the exact
size of the response was a close call in
the deliberations of the monetary policy
committee
but we should also keep things in
perspective
today we have increased bank rate by 25
basis points to 0.5 percent
that is a change that will be felt by
households and businesses around the
country
but rates nevertheless remain very low
by historical standards
the extent of any further tightening of
monetary policy will depend on the
medium-term prospects for inflation
the npc judges that
if the economy develops broadly in line
with the february report central
projection
some further modest tightening and
monetary policy is likely to be
appropriate in the coming months
but it would be a mistake
to extrapolate simplistically from what
we have done today
and assume that rates are now on an
inevitable long march upwards
the pace and extent of any further
monetary tightening will as always
depend on how the economy evolves
and on a number of developments which
are highly uncertain
we face a trade-off between strong
inflation and weakening growth
for example domestic wage and cost
pressures could continue to build
and the increase in import costs may not
ease off as expected
conversely as illustrated in an
alternative scenario in the report
developments in wholesale gas prices
could cause inflation to fall below
target in two and three years time
there is therefore much uncertainty
the npc will it's guessing needs to be
said by me remain very vigilant
so with that ben dave and i will be
happy to take your questions
uh thanks andrew with that to the
questions uh usual drill really please
wait for the microphones to get to you
when you're called on please state your
name and the organization you work
through for and we will get to as many
as possible uh first faisal
then ed
bbc thanks governor um
are you saying that you can start to see
the beginnings of a wage price spiral
and how do you communicate that to uk
households given the sort of
not unique nature but the special nature
of the situation that we're in the terms
of trade shock that you talked about
to communicate to households that
because their energy bills have pushed
up inflation
their mortgage bills might also go up
that's a tricky one
uh why don't you have a go explaining
that
it is tricky for us all um let me say
that i'm
most decidedly not going to use the
phrase wage price spiral we're not uh
we're not in the territory of that
phrase in my view
what we are seeing and you may
observed i referred a number of times to
the survey that our regional agents have
done actually very contemporaneously
they finished it literally only only a
week or two ago
is that we are seeing um upward movement
in uh
what firms expect to be wage settlements
after adjusting for all the sort of the
various covert related um effects on the
data
i think the underlying rate of wage
growth is somewhat higher than we would
expect it to be at this point in the
cycle that's something we've observed
before
but coming on to the main first of your
question i mean you're correct that of
course this is a difficult a difficult
situation um
yeah we are we all hope coming out of
the covered period
um there is there is good news in that
that the economy has broadly recovered
its pre-covered level of output i think
another very good piece of news is that
you know let's let's put our hand up i
think all of us you know afford
unemployment would be higher than it
actually has been and is and that is
very good news
but i'll finish by saying and this is
the hard message i know that
we are facing the squeeze so andrew
bailey there the governor of the bank of
england just talking us through
that earlier announcement that the bank
is raising the interest rate from 0.25
to 0.5 percent a lot about the economy
today lots of breakdown and a lot to
take in really we'll be doing that
throughout the day here on sky news but
for now let's go back to piccadilly
where those bafta nominations were just
announced in the last half hour our arts
and entertainment correspondent katie
spencer is there for us katie
thank you
i feel like we couldn't be more
different could we off the bank bank of
england you come to us over at
piccadilly um baftas though what an
upset i feel like if there was an apple
car that
was going to be upset
i'm gabbling away
i'm joined by the red carpet host of
bafta tom allen and aj doody it was
exciting though wasn't it the
nominations june we weren't expecting
june were we phenomenal i mean it's just
incredible and like you said very
exciting indeed because we weren't even
allowed to know until we got handed that
card we have no idea absolutely i think
there's i mean there's some surprises
and i think somebody was surprised by
some of the people uh who are included
who haven't been mentioned already you
know have been quite um quiet on on
those kind of articles where people like
it's going to be this person it's going
to be that film um there's some real
surprises and i think it really
celebrates well in films around the
world but particularly the great swell
of british talent i'm so excited for
that have you divvied up who's guessing
who on the red carpet lady gaga i mean
you know what we've we've not talked
about that however
i will fight you tom
for lady gaga and lee and our daughter
campaign
that's going to be if we're all like
shuffling i've got no actually i've got
a question actually um well
i really like what you're wearing thank
you um we really wanted to just bring a
sense of well a bit of uh silliness bit
of chaos to proceedings which we hope is
uh brings people in across the threshold
of the the ceremony so we can have a bit
of a laugh with everybody that's what we
wanted to do it's gonna be fun so i hope
to see everyone there on the